اهلا بك معالي الوزير ودعني ابدا معك
وجهه نظرك في ما يشهده العالم اليوم كيف
يمكن وصفه الى اي مدى ينبغي علينا ان نعيش
مع هذا الوضع
من الناحيه العالميه
[موسيقى]
في سعر العديد من المواد الاوليه
معنا
التضخم في العديد من الدول
تقريبا
في السنوات الاخيره يعني العدد الجبلي
اصبحنا تقريبا في 650 مليون شخص
تحت الخط الفقر همم وهذا بالاضافه بالطبع
الى مخاوف كبيره من ناحيه النمو في العديد
من الدول خاصه من الدول الكبيره ممكن نقود
وممكن حتى انكماش الانقسام همم اقتصادي
وهذا سيؤثر طبعا على بقيه دول همم العالم
هذا كله طبعا انضاف الى السياسات
الاقتصاديه المعتمده حاليا لو خاصه سياسه
النقديه وارتفاع النسبه المديريه في
العديد من البنوك المركزيه في العالم التي
ستؤثر سلبا على النمو الاقتصادي يعني
ارتفاع نسبه المديريه ستؤثر سلبيا على
النمو الاقتصاديه في المجال القصير
لها ما يبررها على الصعيد العالمي
هي صراحه
يعني الانظمه الموديلات القديمه الموجوده
الهاتف المحليه ولكنها تداعيات كبرى لا
تدير كبرى على الشرائح الضعيفه اولا لانها
تدفع في اسعار اكبر الغذاء والتنقل وما
الى ذلك تدفع اكثر همم النساء يعني
النقديه والقروض
وليست من ميزانيه همم كبيره وانت فعلا
الفائده سيظهر لما ننظر على نسبه التضخم
واحتمال الناس التضخم بالارتفاع بالنسبه
نعم للناس ده اجماليه ولكن لما ننظر
بالتحديد بعض الشرائح هي لا تساعد وكذلك
كل الاقتصاديين تقريبا وخاصه للدراسات
القديمه بما في ذلك يعني هناك همم اصحاب
همم
قالوا اللي همم ال- ال- الزياده في النسبه
المديريه سوف تؤثر سلبا على همم على همم
على المستوى الاقتصادي في المستوى القريب
والمتوسط لان الشركات طبعا يعني يهتم
التكلفه اكبر سوف تست- ال- الاشخاص
يستاهلها يكون اقل انتاج سوف ينقص
الاستثمار سوف ينقص التشغيل سوف ينقص
القدره الشرائيه
لذلك ندخل في تلك الدوامه
السياسات وراينا حتى في لما طبق وهذه
السياسات التاثير على نسبه نسبه التضخم لم
تكن كانت اقل من المرج همم ذلك كل الحظر
من هذه الاليات الخطيره الخطيره جدا والتي
اثرت سنه خاصه على الشرائح ضعيفه